[Applaudissements]
bonsoir je sais bonsoir bonsoir
les amis ça fait très très longtemps
[Rires]
et le regret des homosexuels pourquoi tu
le dis que maintenant
on se fait des années
on se voit plus j'ai hésité je me dis
j'y vais j'y vais pas ouais
pas du tout parce que parfois c'est pas
toi qui anime
j'ai un jeu pour bouger un vrai ou faux
un jour dans ma vie
Béatrice Rosen m'a couru après presque
toute une journée après j'étais habillé
en clown c'est vrai c'est vrai elle m'a
assommé avec un vase pendant mon sommeil
elle m'a fait des trucs chelou non je me
suis réveillé dans une autre dimension
dans une maison lointaine dans une forêt
vrai ou faux
[Applaudissements]
il y a très longtemps c'est notre vie
vraiment faux moi aussi ah je me suis
réveillé avec Mathieu Delormeau
et tu m'as forcé
[Applaudissements]
le malaise
avec une amie commune et cet ami commune
habiter chez moi attends mais qui
veut
pas dire le blaze absolument rentrer
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je te jure que je le répète après moi
j'ai entendu
[Applaudissements]
qui c'était je suis surpris de ne pas
être rentré avec elle
un moment tu étais cela dit
tu aurais pu dire le nom
c'est pas une émission les choses après
buzz ou quoi
[Rires]
les réseaux les réseaux les réseaux
allez-y pour qu'on parle de cette
émission
[Rires]
de vous on a besoin de vous c'est toi
c'est pourquoi je te vois plus comme ça
mais je sais pas mais je comprends pas
moi je suis là je suis bien ta soirée
à côté de moi ce que je veux bien
amenez-moi une petite table déjà un
guéridon ils ont ils ont préparé déjà
c'est pas parce que tu ne pas connu que
tu n'es pas un acteur
il a compris
dans un tracteur
j'ai envie de faire une séquence sur ma
vie et je vous jure qu'elle n'est pas
prévu du tout même lui n'est pas du tout
compte c'est quoi la séquence j'ai envie
parce qu'on c'est rare qu'on ait des
très grandes stars pour moi c'est un ami
mais une grande star c'est vrai que
comme c'est un très très bon ami j'ai
tendance à oublier que c'est une star et
des fois je parle comme une merde
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je te montre juste un truc et il y a un
gars
il y a juste un gars frère tu sais qu'on
est en plein hiver
[Rires]
elle est où ta femme à la maison
jamais bon ça
tu vas faire quoi tu veux faire une
entrée tu veux faire une entrée
avec lui
[Applaudissements]
ça dérange si je t'appelle
[Rires]
un truc d'impro c'est fou l'émission
c'est Georges c'est mon manager OK
[Applaudissements]
s'il vous plaît en Italie c'est une
émission italienne
et j'arrive avec mon manager italien
et vous vous êtes tous c'est pas jaloux
et vous avez des tickets
ce soir les amis
nous avons la chance d'avoir avec nous
une des plus grandes stars
internationales elle nous amène celui
qui l'a amené jusque là celui qui l'a
pris quand il n'était rien celui qui l'a
amené au firmament pour la première fois
ce soir vous allez rencontrer
c'est son manager Gad Elmaleh et Georges
très content de vous voir bonjour
[Applaudissements]
Est-ce que nous t'étais je voudrais
remercier parce que voilà c'est rare que
les gens disent un peu voilà parle des
gens qui ont aidé à les mettre dans la
lumière genre c'est quelqu'un qui m'a
jamais lâché dans les tempêtes dans les
tempêtes il a été
je voulais juste dire merci en plus il a
vécu des choses terribles et
merci
[Rires]
bravo
ouais
je ne suis pas producteur je pense qu'on
peut avoir une bonne séquence tu sais ce
qu'on fait la guerre d'ici on refait 42°
à l'ombre de la 3 on a une minute pour
les séduire
et TPMP c'est que dans les autres
émissions tout ça c'est avant que
l'émission
moi je vais vous laisser
vous allez rencontrer Gad Elmaleh voilà
c'est une petite rencontre d'une minute
Agathe je suis d'accord vous kiffez avec
lui vous avez la chance de lui parler
parce que des stars vous envoyez pas
beaucoup quoi qui tu vois parfois tout
personne soit tu vois que ta mère toi tu
vois des camions pourquoi tu bois des
vaccins et toi tu vois rien voilà et toi
tu m'as encore moins alors la soirée
j'ai passé des jours avec Elton John et
Julio
j'adore moi pour moi il est au dessus
non pour moi tu es au dessus non
tu as envie de passer un petit moment
égal
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
une voiture
ça passe depuis longtemps le feeling
est-ce que c'est parce que j'ai tout le
temps au Maroc que j'ai aussi cette
culture
du Maroc où j'ai envie de te dire déjà
chacune d'être là avec moi
[Musique]
est-ce que c'est ça est-ce que c'est la
phrase de Voltaire on est beau que dans
les yeux de l'autre et quand je te
regarde j'ai l'impression d'exister
[Musique]
un humoriste c'est pas seulement des
textes sinon ça serait Arthur un
humoriste non c'est pas méchant mais un
humoriste
je te trouve luisant
je trouve brillant parce qu'il est ému
hein
tu bois quoi une sud une suce
ça déjà on verra et
pas avoir une chut s'il vous plaît
au-delà des textes tu as un univers il y
a l'univers gade comme et tu bouges
extrêmement bien et moi je suis très
sensible de gens qui bougent bien parce
que les gens qui bougent bien et on le
sait aussi ce sont des gens qui ont un
univers partis non ce sont des gens qui
bougent bien partout d'accord ce sont
des gens qui qui aiment la vie ce sont
des gens qui savent qu'ils connaissent
l'amour qui savent faire l'amour
une salle comme ça c'est sûr des hommes
et des femmes moi tu m'as déjà séduite
en je ne t'intéresse plus parce que
c'est conquis c'est qui tu vois mais
est-ce que moi je t'ai un petit peu
séduit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
moi je suis gêné par cet écran
[Rires]
on est surtout cette personne moi j'ai
même oublié les caméras je suis
tellement bien avec toi avec vous moi je
pense que tu vas vite les oublier les
gars derrière l'amour avec un
[Musique]
grand génie du tout quoi et bien là
ouais je suis bien mais reviens
non mais c'est bon tu l'as parlé
dis-moi alors si j'ai vraiment un truc
de demander c'est est-ce qu'un jour
juste un jour j'adore de ma vie si vous
faites un film ou une scène du Théâtre
du théâtre ou là tu peux juste une
minute j'ai mon rêve ça aurait été de
monter sur scène ou de faire un film oh
merde
juste un jour et personne personne n'a
jamais donné ma chance alors personne et
donc la question est-ce que tu lui
donnerais la question c'est est-ce que
si par hasard vous prévoyez un autre
film ou prévoyez du théâtre vous
prévoyez à one man je peux avoir un tout
petit rôle dedans
mais ça veut pas dire que je suis passé
[Applaudissements]
sa plus belle tenue
[Rires]
une jovialité mais de l'éducation
nationale
il y a un truc c'est quand tu es
convoqué je dirais directeur ou la
directrice et en même temps elle est
sympathique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tous les deux on a pas beaucoup de temps
à perdre vous arrivez à 50 ans
[Rires]
de donner la parole à la télé
est-ce que tu étais sur une île déserte
Daniel et Mathieu qui choisiriez-vous
entre les deux sur une île déserte avec
Mathieu et moi
[Rires]
je réfléchis comme c'est on est sur TPMP
je réfléchis quels sont les associations
qui vont
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je vous regarde tous les deux je vois
des très puissant en ce moment je vois
des hashtags non écoute je suis obligé
sinon tu meurs le temps passe le temps
passe
obligé moi je fais les deux
un peu de courage
non je choisis de ne pas choisir non
mais est-ce qu'on est libre ou pas moi
je dis la vérité moi je choisis Daniel
ah bah toi oui bah alors maintenant la
vérité voilà
prends ton temps mes réponses j'ai pas
envie de mettre au grand jour mon
hésitation bah réponds
[Applaudissements]
Daniel par contre attention je suis un
petit peu là
salut tu vas bien
[Musique]
juste 30 secondes pour m'adresser à toi
gars tu es celui à qui on veut
ressembler tu es celui à qui on veut
être on va être marrant comme toi on
veut rentrer dans les soirées être
marrant comme toi alors en 30 secondes
moi je viens ici pour une récré et je
suis content de rencontrer des gens
comme toi parce que c'était pas prévu
que je rencontre des gens comme toi et
je voulais juste te dire merci parce que
sur un de tes sketchs où tu dis tout le
monde laisse des messages au téléphone
et que c'est important de dire à papa
viens faire des bisous moi j'ai une
histoire avec mon père il y a pas
longtemps j'ai perdu mon papa et grâce à
ton sketch je suis parti du faire des
bisous avant qui part bravo
mon chéri
[Applaudissements]
chérie c'est ton fils oui chérie
je te dis un truc
il a 10 ans j'ai pas de chance ça va toi
sinon
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
tu
as déjà vu les minions
tu connais le personnage de groupe
tu sais que c'est moi qui fait la voix
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je vais rester humble je vais rester
humble Nino je voulais te faire la voix
de gros mais pour toi que pour toi en
live
professeur
nous allons voler la Tour Eiffel mais
enfin celle de Las Vegas bonsoir Nino
il est fort pour aller de façon Nino
tu es content
[Rires]
[Musique]
bonsoir Delphine comment ça va tu nous
appelles d'où
s'il te plaît aucune émission on peut
demander comme ça à l'emporte-pièce à la
la c'est mon génial hibiscus
regarde-moi
c'est incroyable
bonsoir Gad je vous appelle de Boulogne
je suis vraiment ravie de vous voir
je voulais vous dire que je voulais vous
dire que je vous admire beaucoup pour
toi
ça me mousse je voulais vous dire que je
vous admire beaucoup parce que vous êtes
un artiste complet vous dansez
incroyablement bien
vous pouvez incroyablement bien vous
êtes drôle et en plus de ça vous avez
une curiosité une ouverture au monde et
une spiritualité et une sagesse
incroyable que j'ai découvert dans votre
film qui s'appelle reste un peu qui est
le plus beau film que j'ai vu de ces
dernières années donc
[Applaudissements]
je te le dis ok alors moi je dois juste
je peux passer un coup de fil
mais
c'est plein de cadeaux
vous ça vous change parce que c'est
toujours la même chose
oui oui on approche tes 500000
c'est un tout petit film enfin dans le
budget la conception mais je suis très
très heureux et c'est un film qui
rassemble qui rassemble les communautés
c'est un message de paix important donc
voilà ça c'est mes parents qui jouent
exactement
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
depuis peut-être 25 ans tout le monde se
connaît depuis
c'était avant ou après mon cœur voilà
c'est venu visiter un appartement qui
m'appartenait à l'époque que je voulais
acheter
ça nous a un peu rapproché on s'est
croisé beaucoup sur les est-ce que je
peux
je peux dire un truc dont je me rappelle
non c'est pas ça j'ai il y avait une
batte de baseball près de son lit
je ne connaissais pas bonjour Émilie
batte de baseball tu vois voilà ça c'est
ma chambre à coucher avec une batte de
base-ball
déjà beaucoup d'argent
beaucoup on s'est vu beaucoup croisé
dans sur les les compètes de cheval oui
de monter à cheval pas moi mais tu es
une fiancée et on se croise tout le
temps comme quoi on est vraiment amis
dans les dans les aéroports passe son
temps est dans le même langage
complètement et je me disais puisqu'on
est très amis on est vraiment comme ça
est-ce que tu aurais pas 500 mille
balles
[Applaudissements]
tu peux pas continuer après il a eu tu
as vu il y a ce qu'on appelle un setup
un build up et une punchline exactement
non je dois ranger je dois ranger là
[Applaudissements]
et je vais vous expliquer vous êtes un
des regrets de ma vie et là je réalise
un rêve non les regrets c'est il y a
quelques années je vous ai vu marcher
dans les rues de Paris près de la place
de la République je me souviens très
bien sûr
vous n'étiez pas seul le seul mec qui
fait des dépassements sur trottoirs et
en fait si vous aviez été seul j'étais
venu vous voir et je vous aurais dit ce
que je vais vous dire là vous êtes pour
moi essentiel dans ma vie je vous ai
toujours admiré adoré vous êtes et à
Fatou non mais je sais mais je suis
vraiment ému et je sais c'est un peu
gênant
parce que vous êtes un acteur
exceptionnel à l'image de votre dernier
spectacle là parce que vous parlez
directement aux gens et vous m'émouvez
chaque fois vous m'aimez chaque fois que
vous parlez et quand je vous suis pas
venu vous voir j'ai eu ce regret
j'aurais aimé passer la soirée avec vous
comme ça assis sur une chaise
et vous dire que ce que vous donnez aux
gens c'est un bonheur que vous ne pouvez
pas imaginer
je vous aime monsieur le malais voilà ce
que je voulais vous dire
[Applaudissements]
deux choses d'abord merci infiniment et
merci aussi de pas m'avoir arrêter dans
la rue
[Applaudissements]